[Music]
in 1921
the predominantly black neighborhood of
greenwood in tulsa oklahoma
was victim to one of the biggest
massacres on u.s soil
more than 1 000 african american homes
and businesses
were looted and burned to the ground
and for decades the massacre went untold
white businessmen who ran the city
realized that
tulsa had a huge pr problem and they
were determined to bury the story
but on the heels of the reignition of
the black lives matter movement
there's been national attention brought
to the massacre through news outlets
in 1921 a white mob burned green wood to
ash
as well as pop culture
[Music]
the story is now getting the attention
it deserves
but the massacre is only half of that
story
what happened after the massacre is just
as important
the real story here is the story of the
indomitable human spirit it's about
these remarkable black people
who had vision they created something
that was of national renown
they watched it destroyed
unjustly most of them remained
they were resilient they rebuilt even in
the face of great
hostility
in order to understand the massacre in
tulsa you have to understand the context
around it
so the national context is something
that sociologists and historians often
call the low point of race relations in
america
because it was a proliferation of
so-called race riots these were
invasions of black communities all
across the country
1919 was dubbed red summer with riots in
dozens of cities around america in what
was mostly
white on black violence
[Music]
greenwood however dodged those riots and
actually
flourished because of the oil boom more
than 10
000 people lived there people were
coming in daily to this incredible boom
town this oil city
of tulsa jobs were plentiful plenty
people had you know
regular steady paychecks it was like a
main street really
so you would have beauty salons and
barber shops
laundries grocery stores restaurants
so this was kind of an every man's
paradise
owned by black folks concentrated
in a 35 square block area that abuts
downtown tulsa
during that era a successful black
community was met with white resentment
and greenwood was no different the idea
was
gain economic power gain wealth and then
you will get respect
and with respect will come political
power well just the opposite happened in
tulsa
if you gain economic power you will
court resentment and violence
ultimately white americans can get very
upset
and jealous when they see african
americans who have things
cars nice homes that they don't have
there's no question that part of that
jealousy
was part of the fuel for what became the
tulsa race massacre
but it really wasn't the spark that
began it
that spark was a black boy accidentally
touching a white girl in an elevator
tulsa was a tinder box a powder keg
needing only some sort of igniter or
catalyst
that event involved two teenagers dick
rowland 19 years old
shoeshine boy who works downtown sarah
page 17 years old
white girl who operates an elevator in
downtown drexel bouldin
[Music]
what we think happened is as dick
stepped onto the elevator
he tripped he reached his hand out he
probably
grabbed sarah page she screamed and he
ran out of the elevator
meanwhile a clerk a white clerk in a
nearby store
had concluded that this had been an
interracial rape attempt
and he started to spread that story
the next morning dick roland was
arrested and taken to the courthouse
and that could have been the end of
things
had it not been for the intervention of
the tulsa tribune which the next day
published an article entitled nab negro
for attacking girl in an elevator
it was a false narrative that painted
the portrait
of an attempted rape in broad daylight
in public space
in downtown tulsa after hearing rumors
that dick roland would be
lynched several dozen black world war
one vets assembled
with weapons to confront the mob as you
might imagine wards are exchanged
between the larger white group and the
smaller black group
white man tries to take a black man's
gun the gun discharges
chaos ensues the violence lasted roughly
16 hours
black men put up a fearless defense of
the greenwood community
but ultimately the mob spills over into
the greenwood district
burning looting shooting destroying
everything in sight
the destruction of greenwood wasn't just
bad it was
total it's just like a wave that goes
block
by block both movie theaters go up
the public library branch goes up the
african american
hospital is burned 22 churches are
burned
grocery stores restaurants everything is
leveled
in terms of the number of people who
died there are reasonable estimates that
go as
high as 300 and greenwood is you know
physically speaking is gone
property damage estimates range from 1.5
to 2 million dollars
which translates to 25 million dollars
today
[Music]
but this isn't where the story ends the
fact the matter is
is that black tolson's rebuilt greenwood
the community rebuilt it
and that rebuilding was an uphill battle
with
no help from the federal government and
the city of tulsa
actively trying to prevent the
rebuilding the greenwood community began
the long
slow reconstruction of greenwood the
massacre
in the black community became a point of
pride
the fact is that they fought back so
this was a defiant community
it was a proud community and they were
determined to stay
[Music]
so the community we know was rebuilt to
a significant enough
degree to host this national conference
of these black business leaders in 1925.
in other words yes you may kill us
yes you may burn us out but
we shall not be moved we
will persevere we will go forward
greenwood did rise again from the ashes
and by the 1930s and 1940s you can make
an argument
that it was even grander than it was
before
while greenwood was able to withstand
and rebuild after their neighborhood was
raised to the ground
it wasn't able to withstand the second
attack on the community
which was much less obvious but no less
devious
the first of those attacks ironically
was integration
and for many of us that's
counterintuitive because we
we embrace integration as a positive
value but
when integration comes along black
dollars flow outside the community
why because there are more goods and
services
available to black folks at better price
points for
black folks and it undermines the
financial foundation
of the community
the other factor that destroyed
greenwood for a second time
urban renewal urban renewal projects
often have negative effects on
communities of
color because those communities are
often unable to stand
up against urban planning done
by people who don't take into
consideration
the thoughts and values of communities
of color
one of those projects an eight-lane
interstate freeway
was plowed right through deep greenwood
through the heart of the community there
[Music]
it divides the community in such a way
that it's virtually impossible for the
community
to come back together as a cohesive
whole
like it was before the location of the
highway
and greenwood wasn't the only city
destroyed by these freeways
chicago detroit durham the bronx
los angeles all suffered similar
devastating effects from freeways
essentially
ripping a hole directly through black
communities during the 50s and 60s
it's the old cliche if you're not at the
table you're on the menu
certainly i hope that's changing with
movements like the black lives matter
movement what we're seeing today but in
the past
a lot of these communities of color just
didn't have a place at the table didn't
have a voice
and didn't have the number of white
allies that i hope that we have today
[Music]
you